apenas 100 metros separan la ciudad de
reynosa en mexico de la frontera
estadounidense
allí los colchones en el suelo el
hacinamiento y las malas condiciones
sanitarias marcan el día a día de
cientos de migrantes centroamericanos
especialmente hondureños no es un bien
pues obstante como ven ustedes
muchos niños tiran cualquier cosa y hay
mucho insectos
pues eso también lo perjudica también a
uno de adultos tanto como alumno de
adulto y a los niños también huyen del
hambre provocado por la crisis económica
y social que arrastra centroamérica que
se vio acentuada en los últimos meses
por las consecuencias de la pandemia sin
embargo la nueva administración baiden
está deteniendo diariamente la frontera
alrededor de cinco mil personas de
seguir esta tendencia este mes
alcanzarán el récord de deportaciones de
donald trump nos dicen tan agresivo de
que de que usted solo viene a poner la
huella y se va van deportados
pero las deportaciones no frenan a los
inmigrantes en su empeño este mismo
martes un grupo de unos 400 migrantes
hondureños formaron una nueva caravana
con destino a eeuu
buena parte niños no acompañados como
muchos de los que llegaron en los
últimos días alentados por las palabras
de joe biden y wifi
a los únicos que no vamos a dejar
sentados aquí al otro lado del río
grande solo y sin ayuda son los niños al
sur en febrero más de 9.400 menores
cruzaron la frontera según las
autoridades más de 14.000 en este mes de
marzo muchos de ellos esperan
reencontrarse con algún familiar al otro
lado de la frontera y siete años de
nueve nadie mamá siento un gran vacío de
razón y se va a seguir quiero volverlo a
llenar con amor de actualmente en torno
a 18.000 menores se encuentran en
albergues bajo custodia del gobierno
estadounidense